all right guys so
I have spent the last couple weeks
genuinely trying to think of something
that women are better at and this didn't
come out of malicious intent this didn't
come out of trying to put women down or
whatever genuinely I was just looking at
some numbers I'm like what are women
better at well the premise is women are
more caring and nurturing
well
if so why are we more likely to kill
infants and elders
wouldn't the most caring and nurturing
gender so then I was like okay I guess
that number doesn't make sense
so then then I start asking myself
what about teaching women are better
teachers
turns out we have ruined the education
system we can two women cannot teach as
effectively as one man
okay we're not better teachers all right
chefs we're the cooks right we're women
are better Cooks
wrong all the top Michelin chefs are men
then I was like okay what about
what about aren't there more female
doctors
no no no if you look at the top doctors
and
like surgery and all the advancements in
the field
it's all run by men
um men then I was like well aren't women
out earning men in cities
um
yes but it's usually in industries that
are subsidized
or by Beauty and men still pay 80
percent of the taxes 70 to 80 percent of
the taxes so then I'm thinking all right
all right women have to be better at
something
okay I guess we're not more nurturing
we're better parents right we have to be
better parents well
it looks like single mother homes
are the rude basically everything wrong
with Society they're more likely to go
to homeless the kids are more likely to
be homeless mental institution I mean
you name it
we suck at raising kids by ourselves and
what I realized
is women
can only be shoot sorry guys the best
version of ourselves
under the authority of a guy whether if
it's at work it's in a company they
built
if it's at home
it's under the authority of male
headship of the household
if it's in society
well it's really only under guys
Authority
so
I've sort of concluded that men are just
Superior beings
I don't say this to be mean
I don't say every single man
but I will say
that I can't think of one thing
that women are better at that numbers
back up
but I don't know maybe I'm just an old
sexist so let me know in the comments
like the video guys I'll talk to you